les phrases choc des mots crus les
prénoms de femmes assassinées des cris
d'alarmé lancés dans des lieux très
publique
une campagne né d'un constat le nombre
de françaises tuées par leur conjoint
est en hausse
plus d'une centaine depuis janvier au
moins deux par semaine l'idée vient de
cette militante de 28 ans qui cherche à
secouer la société française on veut
inonder les espaces publics pour rendre
sa visible que ça s'arrête centre
revendications veut arrêter de compter
nous mart un message clair un hommage
éphémère à ces femmes souvent anonymes
inconnue voici l'un des visages derrière
ces statistiques
une femme d'affaires brillante entouré
d'amis assassiné il y a cinq mois c'est
des boutons c'est horrible on se sent un
salut marie-alice dibon avait 53 ans
soumise à des violences psychologiques
tué parce qu'elle allait mettre fin à
une longue relation penser qu'une femme
puisse être assassiné par la personne
qui a partagé son intimité gers est elle
est ultra vulnérables c'est c'est la
circonstance la plus aggravante qu'on
puisse imaginer sa soeur hélène de pons
et interpellent les autorités et
réclament un système judiciaire plus
rapide à protéger les femmes en détresse
on nous dit que ce sera se permettra des
traitements sous 15 jours
c'est bien mais en espagne ces 72 heures
etc des tribunaux dédié bousculé par une
mobilisation de plus en plus visible le
gouvernement français promet d'agir et
d'ouvrir plus d'hébergement d'urgence
autre suggestion davantage de centres
comme celui ci où les femmes en danger
peuvent consulter toute une gamme de
spécialistes de la psychologue à
l'avocate en passant par la
massothérapeute défaite à metz multiair
pas du tout comme victime est dans un
déni total un modèle unique en france
qui vise à mieux coordonner l'aide
offerte aux victimes m peut-être
accompagnée par défi
la cofondatrice de l'association wendy
mentionne aussi le besoin de mieux
former ceux qui peuvent aider une femme
en détresse des médecins jusqu'aux
policiers souvent les professionnels non
habitués à rencontrer des victimes
ont tendance à balayer un peu un dépôt
de plainte à ne pas donner suffisamment
d'importance à l'ecoute et aux moyens
qui doivent être mis dans une situation
d'urgence tout le monde avait son mot à
dire sur cet homme et personne n'a dit
assez fort dans ce combat les militants
espèrent aussi changer les mentalités
si aujourd'hui les hommes tuent c'est
parce que quelque part dans leur tête et
les inscrits qui peuvent le faire que
ils ont sept ce droit de vie ou de mort
sur la femme qu'ils épousent
et ces rappels macabre n'apparaissent
plus que sur les murs de la capitale
on en retrouve aussi dans une dizaine de
villes françaises et même dans d'autres
pays
comme quoi le problème n'est pas que
français ici yann et du mont-bart en
radio canada à paris